All right, folks, welcome back.
It's going to be a short little commentary on basically what I went with today, giving
commentary through Twitter.
You're welcome to go over to my Twitter feed and go through it.
It's a lot because I was going all day long with it.
And I was kind of walking people through their own charts to kind of get a better feel for
what to expect and where the real set up was going to be for today.
Before I get into all that, just know that everything that I said is time and date stamped
so that way there's no tomfoolery about it and only the diligent are going to want to
go through something like this.
And I put the readers on Twitter through the meat grinder today.
I literally took them through every minor fluctuation, explained why it should do this
and should do that, and ultimately setting up way before it happened, the three o'clock
to four o'clock short, outlined it in detail, gave the reasons why it should take place.
Everything's there.
And everything I'm going to say in short highlight here is obviously found in the tweets.
So we have an outside day here yesterday, big down close day.
An outside day is a day that's higher than the previous day and lower than the previous
day's low.
So here's previous day's high, it went higher, here's previous day's low, it went lower.
So all of this range is outside of the previous day's range and it closed down.
When this happens, there's typically this type of price action formation, but it's really
included with the odds in your favor if we're trading down to an old low but fall short
of it.
This is usually where that double bottom idea comes in and it feels safe to, if you're trading
like me, look for a run through that old low, but if they stop it short, it tends to be
a choppy day, especially if you have an outside day with down close.
So let's go into an hourly chart.
All right, so here's the price action for today.
We're going to look inside this little tiny little fractal right here.
And I can zoom in here, all right.
So we have old highs in here.
If you look at the high here, it comes in at 39.33.25, I mentioned that level today
I mentioned it a few times that we were going to trade up to that.
And I built the idea that looking at price studying in the way that I teach it, it would
be very easy to fall victim in this type of trading day, where it's choppy, it's listless
trading back and forth, and how to anticipate it, what to look for.
And I want to go into the five minute chart real quick.
Okay, and here's the five minute chart.
And I'm going to add some annotations here.
So here is the 39.33.25 level, that's why that level was mentioned in the tweets.
This is the low at 38.72.25, and the old low on the daily chart that did not get traded
through is at 38.55.
And notice we just fell short of reaching that at 38.56.
So we went one handle short of that, started trading higher.
And I mentioned how the market many times can present opportunities that look like it's
likely to form a setup, but it really doesn't really come to fruition.
And if you look at the range here.
Okay, I'm highlighting this sphere that you got right there, okay, how we traded up into
the market, started working lower, created a small little fair value gap in here, bumped
into that, traded lower, nothing really in here to work with in terms of the model.
So nothing here is a short, we were talking about all that this morning.
So as the market was trading around in this area, I mentioned how it was likely to be
a 50-50 probability.
That means it's likely to go higher just as well as it is likely to trade lower.
Okay, so what's the benefit in that?
Obviously, anybody can come into it with a 50-50 expectation.
But it really statistically moves to 50-50 when we start trading back into the middle
of the range.
Okay, so this imbalance here, the fair value gap, it should have offered a little bit more
movement lower.
Why wouldn't it go down and take out this short-term low?
It went below this short-term low here and then started rallying, working towards the
relative equal highs over here.
I mentioned early on that it would go to 39.33 and a quarter.
That's where it would go.
But I favored, in other words, in terms of bias for the longer term, I favored the 38.55
level down here for sell side.
I don't think that they're done with it down there.
But we have to take every single trade idea based on its current dealing ranges.
And what's a dealing range?
Well, a dealing range would be like from this high down to that low, and we measure those.
Yes, it trades up into that imbalance and trades down to a short-term low.
That's a tradeable opportunity there.
But it's not very clear after that.
It just goes back and forth, chopping.
Short-term lows are taken.
High is taken here.
We trade back and forth.
All of this is really ugly type of price action.
And I mentioned that we would go to 39.33 and a quarter back here, and it ran right
up into it, cleared those relative equal highs, broke down.
Traded back down into the range.
And I started talking about how the real setup that would be formed by my content, by the
things that make sense in the algorithm, would deliver a specific framework today.
I told everybody on Twitter, you can go back and look at it, to take a vertical line and
do three o'clock New York local time and four o'clock.
And that would be the setup that forms to take us back down into the middle of the range.
And I tell everyone in the tweets to study the middle of the daily range.
So what does that mean?
If you look at what the high was and the low, right in here, that's the middle of the range.
We ran above the short-term high.
So we have relative equal highs here and relative equal highs here.
So there's buy-side resting here.
You can find how the market would use the running up to take out the buy-stops, to squeeze
anybody that was short and then trail their stop-loss down, and also to induce people
into thinking it's going to go higher, so that way it builds up liquidity below these
lows.
What kind of liquidity?
Sell-side liquidity, because they're going to protect their what?
Long positions.
But the main thing was focusing on the middle of the range here.
So, if we're looking for setups that are going to be based on a run above for buy-side
and then pull back into the range, it needs to be specific in terms of time.
I gave a very specific window between 3 o'clock and 4 o'clock in the afternoon.
So we go into an hour chart.
We're going to go into a minute chart.
Okay.
And you can see here the market rallies above, bumps into the buy-side liquidity.
SmartMoney uses that to go short.
This is exactly what I outlined beforehand.
It's all in the tweets.
It's not ambiguous.
It's very specific.
I tell you exactly when the trade is going to form.
I tell you exactly how it's going to happen.
I'll tell you the framework, the logic, the narrative, everything.
It's going to pull back to the middle of the range.
Here is the breakdown.
Here?
Let me take this.
Is this a swing low?
Yes.
Is this a fair value gap?
Does it trade back up into that range?
Yes.
It works lower, back into the middle of the range.
Let me put this back where I want it.
Okay.
And if I add the annotations, you can see right there.
I sold short at 39.40 and three-quarters, and I took four of them off at 39.08 and three-quarters
middle of the range.
And you can see there still is a position there with partials taken off already.
Okay, and the limit order down here at 38.55.
It doesn't matter if it goes down there now.
I don't care.
But I have a position in play, should it do so.
And I want everyone to understand that there are people out there, obviously, who want
to say stupid things because they either want to get a rise out of me or they feel that
they're competition and they want to get a lot more attention for themselves.
Honestly, if you want to build attention around yourself, just do things that warrant people's
attention placed on you.
But for anyone that obviously did not spend time with me today, this is going to be rather
boring.
It's going to be pointless to you.
But I walked through all of the things that days like this where it's choppy, where it's
just going back and forth, back and forth.
And this was not read wrong.
I purposely took everybody into the marketplace through their own chart and told them to think
about what was going on in their own mind, what other traders would be thinking.
So that way you could really capture what it feels like to be in there looking for your
own setups and try to think critically about it.
I outlined in advance where the setup based on the things I teach up here where it runs
the buy stops, we pair with that and then pull back to the middle of the range and it
does so beautifully.
All of this in here is really hard choppy price action.
It's very, very difficult to trade in those types of ranges because they can come back
on you and stop you out and just go nowhere for a long period of time.
So if you know what you're looking for in terms of what the algorithm is going to do
and the algorithm on days like this, this is called a consolidation day.
And what happens is this, the market starts trading, creates an initial range and then
stays in that range until the afternoon.
At three o'clock, it used to be the bond close that started this whole thing, but now it's
just three o'clock to four o'clock when equities close, the closing bell.
That sets the tone for on close orders.
So what that means is what was going on prior to three o'clock?
The market was rallying up.
What did it go up for?
The buy side liquidity.
But traders don't look at that as a breakout to go higher and they're going to pair that
with the market participants that are considered smart money.
So that's exactly what I outlined.
This is exactly what transpired.
Everybody in the Twitter feed were following along.
I mean, granted, there were a few people and you can go through and see who they were.
They weren't really paying attention because they came into the conversation late and I
went a long day today just tweeting, tweeting, tweeting.
What you don't know is I had my son sitting next to me and I'm outlining things to him
and I'm explaining what should take place in the marketplace.
Plus, I'm also sending out tweets.
So my mind was divided between all of that.
So it was very difficult not only to predict what you all were thinking and thinking about
what should be transpiring in price action, plus literally walking through with my son
what to anticipate, expect, and see in price action through his lens.
He was actually executing in a live account.
He has his AMP account linked right through TradingView so you can trade directly right
from the chart.
So he's plugging away on my laptop right next to me.
And his account was able to grow from $6,000 at the beginning of the week.
Now it's at $10,000.
That's real money.
That's live money.
And when I hear about people that say the stuff that I teach doesn't work or if I can't
call the market and when people sit there and they spend the entire day with me and
I outline everything and I outline this very specific trade here way before it even forms,
before the market even went up there, I'm explaining all that.
That it went right to where I said it was going to go, run the stops, then sink it back
down to the middle of the range.
Go back and look at the tweets.
I can't edit them and I'm not deleting anything.
Okay.
So if I make a mistake, a spelling error, you're just going to have to deal with it
because I don't want any deleted tweets, zero.
So if you'd like to follow me and all that stuff, just save everything, save it all.
I don't care.
The point is I want you to save them.
What exactly what I said the last time I was on Twitter, save my tweets, save them because
you're going to see things that prove obviously what I'm talking about.
It proves that I have the visibility that I can see these things beforehand and there's
a lot of people out there that will just not want to put the work into learning this because
it seems too hard.
They just want to put an indicator on the chart and you know, that's all I want.
Give me a MACD, give me a stochastic and I'm moving average and we'll call it a day.
But they don't give you logic and narrative.
May this give you a crunching of the numbers and that type of thing isn't, in my opinion,
not very beneficial because you're beating up the data of price action versus reading
and understanding what the tape is and that's exactly what I was doing today with everybody
on Twitter.
So there is an application that I was made aware of on Twitter that allows someone to
do, I think if I'm not mistaken, they call them a space or spaces or if I said that wrong,
forgive me.
I'm not going to edit this video, but apparently there's something on the Twitter app that
you can kind of like talk and I think it's just audio where you just talk and people
that are, I guess, following you on Twitter, they can hear you talk.
So I guess in a way it could be like an ICT squawk box, you know, I can kind of like talk
out loud about what I'm looking at, what I think is useful.
It's not a trade setup, obviously, or a signal service type thing because that's not what
I do.
I don't do those things.
So we were studying price action together over my shoulder through tweets and this was
the move I was outlining well in advance early in the day.
I was setting the stage for all this back and forth motion that they're going to drive
it higher to squeeze out traders that were already short from the previous day and trigger
their stop loss right above the old high back here.
They bumped it here on a very shallow run.
Let me take this off.
They bumped it on the, let me take everything on action.
These are relative equal highs.
As it dropped down, they trail their stop loss, those that are short.
So they ran up and bumped it on a shallow basis and then one more time they ran it up
in there, clear them out real nice.
So the logic I was teaching was that would be utilized for smart money at the close between
three o'clock and four o'clock.
So they ran it up there.
All the buy orders that were resting above here or here in the form of protecting short
stops, or not short stops, short positions acting as their stop loss order.
When the market trades above that, those buy stops that are protective in nature, they
become a rushing liquidity wave of willing buyers at the market.
So willing buyers at the market at three o'clock on a day like this where it's consolidated,
it's going to want to go back to the middle of the range.
And that's why I posted and tweeted, study the middle of the range, that's today's range.
So when you look at that type of event, it's going to range bound trade between here's
the 930 or so right there.
So the low of the day there and the high of the day there.
So split that in the middle, there's your midpoint, and it's going to want to gravitate
back to that.
So when you look at price action days like this, and if you're caught up in it, you don't
know what you're doing or you feel like you're just being chopped up, wait until three o'clock.
Because many times at three o'clock to four, the algorithm will do something where it goes
outside the bounds of the daily range like it did here.
It trades up into it and then rams it down and nobody's really allowed to make any money.
Anyone that was long breaking out here gets raped across the coals.
Anyone that's short gets knocked out with a stop loss and they're at a losing position.
And most of the time traders are too afraid to go in here going short where people that
like myself I outlined today in the front of 20,000 people, they all seen it, they all
watched me call it and there it is.
There's my fill and there's the middle of the range partial and I got two inflow.
And just for the sake of completeness, I'm just going to take one of them off while I'm
doing this recording.
So that way I don't have to worry about it at all, you can go to my stop and or go to
my limit and either one's fine by me, I don't care.
So I'm going to try to do a little bit of tomorrow's session.
I'm not going to spend the entire day obviously because I have other things I have to take
care of but I scheduled in today because I had to work with my son and his analysis
and learning and all that stuff.
So I was very proud to see him pushing the button on his account.
He did very, very well.
Had one or two hairy moments where he wasn't thinking like I was hoping he'd be thinking
and had a losing trade, was able to recoup that and pushed his account to over $10,000.
So I'm very proud to see him engaging and doing his own thing and trying to figure out
this stuff on his own.
So yeah, I think we'll talk a little bit through that Twitter application tomorrow.
I don't know how long I'll go but we'll see what we get from that and I think that's going
to be it for this one.
Until I talk to you next time, be safe.